[Music]
traditional workouts often focus too
exclusively on either a few competition
lifts or simple calorie burning
missing the full potential of the human
body
super functional training means training
across disciplines and modalities for
heightened performance in every domain
[Music]
specialization in training only makes
sense for professional athletes the real
world is dynamic changing and
multi-planar
the challenges we are presented with
are protein
our training in every domain should be
as complete as possible strength is not
measured by numbers on a few lifts we
must train all energy systems and we
must train at all speeds
we should be able to exert rapid
explosive force but also measured
nuanced and intelligent adjustments and
strength and we will tap into forgotten
aspects of our performance by addressing
those muscle groups that often go
overlooked
imagine being a little bit stronger a
little bit faster a little bit smarter
and a little bit more energetic how
would that feel
explosive strength with max strength
calisthenics with kettlebells steady
state cardio with hit mobility with
balance meditation with brain training
this is what protein performance means